your career can I talk about your career
[Laughter]
you can't place my life right cuz I'm
looking in your eyes and I'm connecting
so it's almost like I don't have to talk
to you I can just connect with you I
really do I just look in your eyes and I
feel yeah yeah yeah we don't even have
to talk now that we don't yeah but you
know I can't see your audience that's
true we should talk yeah it's keep
staring in each other do you have any
Pottery Barn candles okay can I just say
this yeah I say this yeah I will not
look you anymore
I don't like it you won't look at me
anymore I had cut out glance at you
everyone so but staring makes you
uncomfortable got a little bit my friend
got it I'll look away I just looked away
one day I didn't even know her l'm not
well he calls me he goes you want to be
in my movie you remember that so great
you don't know how grateful I am that
that that touched me it did it warm my
heart you did such a wonderful job you
were took it very seriously your acting
was great I did take a release you were
so attentive and you you have no idea
that touched me thank you
what do you think you know III thought
that we I go wow he we're friends
well yes I wanted to be your friend so
bad but then that was like the first
step toward friendship well so yes years
ago he goes coming to my house he lives
in that same house so we went to
remember baby
same house were early in the morning I
remember and I go where we going
he's like the desert do you remember
that I do yeah yeah and we drove into
the desert and we shot a neutron I was
in the trunk of your car your and we
took my truck my pickup truck why you
were there somebody else was Africa my a
couple of the other actors right and a
cameraman a cameraman yeah it wasn't a
big crew I thought the whole movie with
about three people
he did would I play kangaroo kangaroo
hands O'Reilly okay that's right I play
kangaroo hands O'Reilly yeah
and I remember like you opening up the
trunk yeah and I came out and I had you
were tucked in the back seat oh the back
seat that would hold you up
I'm you had a little kangaroo hey
beautiful you have no idea how deeply
grateful and honored and happy you made
me doing that oh no it did of course do
because I'm saying I want to say to you
I want to say this earlier we went into
a couple of weird areas brought on what
I really wanted to say to you though is
is that um think you know I you know
yes eluent there's something about Mary
so the Rocket Man I mean you're such a
funny guy and I've seen you to stand up
for so many years there's no stand-up
like you're so [ __ ] great and
creative up there and weird and fun man
thank you [ __ ] and so when I did go out
to do that with you it was um I'll
remember for the rest of my life I
didn't know if it was just another like
I'm going to do a bit you know I didn't
I didn't know if it resonated that much
with you what I'm glad to hear that it
connect really something you [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay is that number one right
I don't ask everyone in the room knows
okay I don't leave here no I don't leave
the house to do with food Yeah right
or sometimes I know the audition or if I
might have to go to work by force by
force
right yeah yeah but rarely do I go yeah
I'll go out to the desert with you and
shoot that's there oh well now I'm even
more honored right but because if it was
you I was like I have to I'm gonna do
this this is gonna be amazing I love I
love that guy well you know what's funny
is I I walked up to Bobby and I said hey
Bobby I'd love you to be in my movie and
before I could even tell him what he
goes yeah okay and I didn't have to tell
him the part he didn't want to see the
script it's like I think I sent you the
script two to three days before yeah and
we went there was a you know probably
three or four
or weeks or a month later yeah yeah yeah
yeah and you just were so great and you
just like did it and that's why I was
I'm to this day and and it's such a
beautiful part in the movie everyone
loves you
ah it's so funny and what's the movie
called it's called fudgie wudgie fudge
face it's an indie movie that took me
six years to shoot I did it by myself I
wrote it I directed it I shot it I did
the hair the makeup costumes the
avocations the transportation the props
the I mean is that I edited it I did the
music and in the sound effects I mean I
did the whole damn thing it took me six
years so everyone who's in it is is in a
has a piece of my heart because it was
such a passion project yeah and I think
people get an iTunes they can order it
at my website it's only on DVD that
because I don't know if anyone even has
a DVD player anymore but it set at
Harlan Williams calm but fudgie wudgie
what v gy g fudge face Wow
and I'll never forget we stopped on the
way up to the desert it's about we was
about a two hour hour-and-a-half drive
north right out of LA and we stopped in
the morning at subway to get sandwiches
for lunch and put them in the cooler and
Bobby got like a subway like omelet oh
no they got like egg the egg like the
leg thing yeah yeah and we got out to
the desert and the first thing Bobby did
is he found like an anthill and he put
half his omelet down the anthill the
ants just started swarm like weeping in
the desert for 50 years
[ __ ] omelet they just started
swarming like it look great you made
them happy I think I took a picture of
it I think yeah I think I did that
because I didn't like it yeah
oh so stick it to the ants not me to my
yeah you mean my garbage is their
pleasure that's right you know that old
saying yeah
yeah and then here's another thing their
garbage is like yeah you get it
you also do this special I don't know if
this is right or not in full of in the
forest no I did it in the desert right
rate where we shot remember we shot
behind a great big hill in the desert
yeah
so I owned that hill I bought that hill
goodbye wait wait you bought a hill in
the desert yeah we shot we shot on my
land didn't I tell you that was my land
we were shooting or I did not know that
about 20 acres in the middle of the
desert ahead of it is a giant hill and
so I went back a few years later and I
shot my stand-up comedy special up on
the hill in the middle of the desert
whoa who was there no one it was just me
and I had a tortoise a friend of mine
out a tortoise so it was walking around
it was a walking while I did my stand-up
and a cup while I was doing my stand-up
a couple of wild dogs there's a lot of
wild dogs out there too wild dogs walked
right through my sack just wandered
through and I talked to them and then
they wandered off into the desert
fantastic whoa I had a crew and like
Smitha seven seven cameras and a jib and
a crane and not.we agent had a
helicopter we had a helicopter flying
around and it was amazing how do you do
I mean how do you with the laughs that
we did you put in laughs later oh
nothing I just I just I just heard them
in my head you know it's a it's an act
that I worked on it's an act I worked on
for many years and and I just knew the
timing so well that I just him as I was
doing it I just accounted for the laughs
in my I pretended I could hear them Wow
so if you're watching that this thing
yeah do you don't hear any laugh you
just run just silent silent and it's
beautiful you don't like the comedy the
view is beautiful yeah cuz there's
nothing out there you can just see
forever and then you um he's in an hour
long yeah Wow
kind of i watch one of my favorite shows
is called mozart in the jungle and he
goes through like an artistic block as a
compulsion a composer he's a master oh
and one of the things to break his
artistic block was to perform solely for
himself and without the roar of the
crowd that he was used to beautiful he
was able to elevate himself and elevate
his practice which is sort of similar
they wanted to bring a crowd in and I
won't let them they wanted to bus like
people out and build like like seats
around me and I said no you're missing
the point this is this is about me like
doing stand-up out to the universe to
the world it's not it's not for the
camera there there can't be a wall of
people it's got a it's got to go out to
everything eliminate the ego from the
performance act it was just it was just
me yelling out there was no barrier
there's no walls
there's no curtains there was no roof so
just I did Wow but I did my act but
there was a lot like like I had to
improvise the dogs and there was there
was like some birds flew by and we're
like ah and I pretended they were
heckling and then at one point three
guys in motorized hang gliders buzzed
right over and I just started yelling up
yeah was really yeah it's called the
force of nature Harlan Williams a force
of nature website or queen that's the
same thing on my website it's it's DVD
oh I wish I could use some vitamins and
some help from a doctor online well let
me
[Music]